hello mr shapiro my name is joey stone
i'm from vanden high school in fairfield
california
i was just wondering what are your views
on colorado's new
i guess option to push communism at all
costs
to push communism communism oh well i
mean i'm not aware of
the the kind of provision that you're
talking about in colorado law
uh so i'd have to be familiar with with
what the provision is of law
obviously communism bad also evil also
killed 100 million people
so i'm i'm bewildered by people i'm able
to ride people who who are
are romantic toward communism and it's
it is a gift of being
of growing up in a one thing that all
the communists who live in america have
in common
is that they live in america
move to cuba and then tell me how
wonderful communism is without being a
part of the prevailing regime
[Music]
it's it's easy for michael moore to talk
about the glories of the the cuban
healthcare system while he has his wga
card
uh it's it's a little bit different when
when michael moore
you know would have to live there which
of course he never will
the the people who are the most
anti-communism in america are people who
left communist countries
who actually lived in these places
there's such an inherent level of
ingratitude in america right now it's
astonishing to me
people who people who are born on third
base and think they hit a triple
people who people who live in the most
prosperous free
and wonderful country in the history of
the world bar none not close if you
could be born anytime in any place you'd
be right here and
right now you're guaranteed basically
eight decades on this earth
of health wealth and ease and you're
sitting around going
you know it'd be better if we got rid of
everything that undergirds this and then
we do stuff that's
fair and fair means what i like
saying well i'm sorry but the world did
not begin spinning when you got here
the principles that you hold are not
unique to you and your wealth is not a
natural
part of life people people tend to just
believe that
this is normal that what happens in
america is normal that the norm of human
life is this
that is so not only historically
ignorant but just ignorant of
contemporary circumstance
anywhere outside the west if if people
actually have the ability to take a time
machine
then they might be a little bit more
grateful for what it is they have here
in the united states
and fortunately there is a time machine
it's called an airplane all you have to
do is take that airplane to a third
world country
and you will quickly recognize that the
united states is a damned phenomenal
[Applause]
place